look I don't know what the fork happens
when you die and neither do you but if
this is how it works I get behind it
[Music]
hey folks the good place season four
brings the entire series to a close I've
talked about the good place before I did
a video on why I thought it was that
that it was awesome I think after season
2 or maybe I cannot remember when I did
it this will be my second video on the
show though I'm sad that it's over but
it really did end at the perfect time
really the perfect time to end a show is
that a point at which you're not quite
ready for it to end you don't want to
end too early cuz then you're like oh I
feel like I never really got everything
I was gonna get out of it and while I'm
very sad to see this go I do think it
also probably did everything that it
would that it set out to do and did it
really well on top of that so hats off
to Michael Schur for deciding to end it
where and how he did so I am gonna be
getting into spoilers for this season
I'll hold off on that for a little bit
as has been the case for every season of
the show the cast is absolutely
phenomenal they're all great I mean you
know Gd and Eleanor and Mike humming Ted
Danson Michael my god Janet I think
Janet's still my favorite
Jason is terrific and Shawn became a
much more of a recurring character we
see a lot more of the judge'll so Maya
Rudolph yay
I would still say that of out of the
core group tehani remains the weak link
not that she's bad but she's probably
the character who works though in the
fewest situations she really does need
to be bouncing off the other characters
and she doesn't adapt to a ton of
situations that well whereas I feel like
the other characters are a lot more
malleable and they can work in a lot of
different scenarios
whereas with her four seasons and they
still kind of default to the to the name
drop jokes and you know they they
recycle similar jokes for a lot of the
gate characters but I feel like there's
a lot more variety and say the Florida
jokes for Jason than there were in the
name drop jokes for tehani I think part
of the problem there was they not only
were they all a similar flavor they all
had almost an identical structure to
them that said you know I say she's the
weak link not in the performance the
performance is great and she's also my
favorite part of the bloopers if you
ever watched with him because oh god
British people swear so much and
listening to her swear when she gets
lines wrong it's delightful um but I I
just mean that the character felt like
it had the fewest places to go and
things to do she was the least versatile
character from a writing standpoint but
she does still add to think she's not a
she's not a detriment she's just not as
much of a boost as the other characters
are going into season four I was really
curious as to how this was gonna work
and I really have to take my hat off to
this show for managing to retain its
core concept yet reinvent its structure
and its characters goal season / season
/ season and to not have it feel like
needless prolonging of things to have it
everything feel like a natural
progression not feel like it's a big
repeat of before while at the same time
retaining some
the same elements and obviously the same
characters it's really man this shows
really smart and I don't just mean that
because it drops a lot of philosophy
academic jargon which it does and you
know that makes it that makes it learn
it that isn't what makes it smart what
makes it smart is the way in which this
stuff is deployed and this this season
really did nail a lot so we go into the
season setting up this idea that the
characters we've been following Michael
Ellen or Jason tejani Janet not cheetah
unfortunately because they had to wipe
his brain for complicated reasons from
last season but they are running an
experiment to try and prove that humans
are capable of improving outside of
their experience on earth because if
they can prove that then it means that
the core idea of judging them forever
good place bad place based off their
time on earth is a flawed system and so
the first half of well more than the
first half I guess the first two-thirds
of the season is then dealing with this
batch of people picked by the bad place
because you know the judge is trying to
give both sides of this whole thing a
shot so the folks that you know are the
folks that we'd like are making the
setting up the experiment how it works
whereas the bad place provided the
people now I suppose initially the front
half of season four is probably the
weaker of the two halves of the show of
the season rather which and I said is a
good thing because that means that you
build the better stuff as opposed to
peeking and then dropping off but it it
did take a couple of episodes for me to
really start to get to flow with the
whole you know these these new people
and you know the this this
just pompous rich white guy who thinks
he's God's gift to everything and this
gossip columnist and you know these
characters trying to get them sorted out
and and Chiti and and the woman he was
dating for a while and part of me did
wonder like are they gonna be able to
pull this together but then things
started happening as it went along and
we started getting more depth behind
those characters and continued to peel
back new layers for the characters we
already know and I'm gonna start to get
a bit more into specifics so that's your
initial spoiler warning I will give you
a ooh
another spoiler warning before I get
into the stuff in the back half of the
season the stuff that aired this year as
opposed to the stuff that was done in
2019 first half of the season so there
are a couple moments that to me were
absolute magic in that first half of the
season and you know and there's a lot of
good jokes there's a lot of good bits
there's there's some there's some funny
stuff that goes on with the folks in the
game and the bad place like say we get a
lot more Sean and he's great that's just
fun but there's something really
wonderful about towards the end when
we're getting the judgments about
everybody and I cannot remember the
character's name now unfortunately cuz
we didn't see him in the second half of
the season but the the guy who was the
you know the pompous rich white guy who
assumes he's the best at everything and
that's just natural that he's reaching
the end of his time or they all are and
he suddenly snaps to a realization that
he's not a good person and it kind of
hits him like a ton of bricks and for a
character that has just been so
aggressively infuriating to see that hit
him the
the actor did phenomenal work of that
sinking in and you know any sense of
denial washing away and all the lies
that he tells himself about what a good
person he is and how everyone else is
the problem just sort of falling off his
face and this panic this dread kind of
clutching at him the sense of Oh God and
I'm not gonna say that I've ever
personally had that happen in a moment
but like I've had equivalent parts of my
life I thought that was really well
captured and I love that when it comes
to the judgement initially it's like oh
god he's gonna sink the whole thing
because he got slightly worse during the
experiment whereas everyone else got
better he got slightly worse he went
down by one percent but then they
tracked his overall thing and he was
just getting worse and worse and worse
and then at the very end even though it
didn't bring him back up at the positive
territory it was such a self realization
it pulled him out of a spiral it that
was a really magic moment the other
thing that I really loved in the front
half was a small moment much less
attention paid to it but oh did it make
me so happy
I love with Janet because she gets taken
and a bad Janet put in her place and
Jason's the one who realizes that
because she refers to herself as a girl
and he knows he knows Janet he loves him
and he knows her and there's something
so wonderful about him catching that and
realizing what's going on and then when
he and Michael go on the rescue mission
they seen you know right before they
start you know this little hand cart
down the tracks and Michael says let's
go get our girl back
and Jason just goes not a girl even
though I'm gender-fluid I don't
generally go with you know they pronouns
I don't object to them but I I never
request them and I I don't think of
myself as non-binary but I have friends
who are and you can go back to the
conversation I had a few months ago with
M Middleton who is non-binary and they
talked about how much they loved that
Janet kept iterating not a girl and not
even you don't necessarily objecting to
being referred to as she but just in it
emphasized like that's not what I am and
as a non-binary person I'm really
connected with that and I was so happy
to see that not only not get undermined
because like the way they could have
busted that is you know she feels more
human and then goes I am a girl that
entire element would have been lost
instead not only does it keep it it
affirms it and not only from Janet from
Jason he knows she's not a girl and he
loves her not in spite of that but
because of it he loves who she is who
she is is not a girl he loves this not
girl oh that warmed my heart
quite a bit and now here's your big
spoiler warning because we're gonna get
into the tail end we're gonna get into
the more recently aired episodes
including the finale so that's your last
warning
alright there was something really
heartwarming and just soothing about the
way that it comes to a close first of
all it continues to have great jokes we
get the doorman who loves the frogs that
gets paid off
oh so sweetly he's so cute love him to
death and it's a really fascinating
thing for them to first off have to
think of a whole new
way to even run the afterlife and the
idea that they hit upon basically just
cycling people through over and over and
over again until they become whatever
the best version of them is not
necessarily you know the ultimate
paragon of humanity but whoever was the
best thing that that individual can be
when they hit that then they get
rewarded and in the meantime while it's
rough and the cycle is not necessarily
fun or Pleasant it's not a punishment
it's a chance to learn and a chance to
grow and that's I love that because the
I I'm not excessively really I wasn't
raised in a religious family and while I
have certain general areas of belief
that that I hold on to like the whole
notion of heaven and hell it's never sat
well with me largely because of the
permanence of it especially with hell
the idea that you suffer forever with no
chance at a reprieve so this notion that
no you just you get to try again and
keep trying and keep trying and keep
trying until you get it right and for
some people that will take a lot longer
and for some like I said for some people
that cycle sucks but it's not a
punishment it's just a chance to try
again and the idea that you can get that
chance to try again
again and again and again as however
many times you need it whether it's once
ten fifty five hundred trillion however
many times you need it you'll have that
chance
so I love that and it's funny the idea
of getting bored of heaven oddly had
never actually really occurred to me I
think just because I kind of chalk up
the notion of I can't possibly conceive
of what heaven is
I just kind of go on the assumption well
I guess you don't get bored I don't know
but I like I love that notion of you're
in somewhere that's a reward until
you're ready to be done
there's something very Buddhist about
that which I kind of appreciate
especially given that by and large the
philosophical aspects of the show have
heavily been Western philosophy and
that's not a knock against the show it's
just the reality of it but I really like
that the ultimate answer feels a lot
more Eastern and the idea of ultimately
true peace is just not being part of it
any of it anymore and the idea of this
of this go place that that's your step
to take whenever you're ready
and the last episode seeing the
characters making those steps and
deciding that they're ready and the
sweetness of all of it the sweetness of
Chiti saying to Eleanor I know because
I've known for a while and I've stuck
around regardless to stay with you but
I've been ready to go for a while that
hid a bit Jason and I knew I knew it was
gonna turn out Jason hadn't left yet I
knew he was gonna pop back up again
because like we didn't seem go through
the archway of course he's gonna pop up
yeah the last time we saw him was Janet
saying you can stay here as long as you
want to by either be there for friggin
ever so I knew that was gonna happen but
I love the idea that he waited not
impatiently but peacefully for who knows
how long
until Janet came back his Janet came
back so that he could give her his his
gift it's so sweet and it's so Jason and
the fact that he was able to just hang
out in the woods until she came back
speaks a lot to the growth that he
underwent to get there and be ready to
do that and it really did kind of affirm
yeah he was ready to pass through that
door but then he had one thing left to
do to make sure he got is she got that
thing that does that little trinket and
Michael getting to go on earth and this
sort of dispersion of Eleonora
into the universe and just a tiny piece
of her circling back connecting and
Michael recognizing it I wasn't sure it
was gonna be possible to end this thing
as well as it had been going up to this
point this isn't this is a perfect
ending for this show and I and I also
love that Eleanor's piece comes with
helping someone who is maybe not exactly
but pretty close to the worst version of
Eleanor herself admit that she needs
help and needs change which is something
to Eleanor struggle with for so long
both in life and after Hawaii the layers
of this thing the depth of this thing
the and just the the wonderful warmth
and frequent hilarity of these
characters this show is something really
special
and I'm really glad that I got to enjoy
it start to finish and watch it close so
strongly so that's the good place the
end of it season four what did you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something on down in the comments let's
talk about it if you feel like adding to
your own good point count you can also
like and subscribe because those help me
out and I also have a patreon where you
get various rewards there's a discord
server which is a patreon exclusive and
also some videos including this one
become available to patreon supporters
24 hours before they go live for
everyone else so if you feel like
supporting me in that way I would
certainly appreciate it but I'm not
gonna tell you what to do because at the
end of the day you're the council I'm
just running the meetings and until next
time keep it sleazy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]